two bright students from the same school
with very different plans well I've been
predicted a star and two ways and to get
into King's College London I'm gonna
have to get create
I've just finished college and I'm
taking the gap year out to do to do an
apprenticeship this year the government
has begun removing the cap on the number
of students with 30,000 extra places but
is that a good thing
degrees are always important and always
needed by employees because for example
the degrees the 45 in place are not
gonna be just allocate to one university
so they're not just going to be lower
down but if you shared out equally to
all the universities then it becomes
just it becomes a good increase I would
say that University isn't the best
option for all students I believe that
universities you know are a really good
you know career career booster you gain
you gained you gain experience again
theoretical knowledge on your chosen
profession but I wouldn't say that it's
your only pathway that kind of
reluctance has led some universities to
offer cash giveaways to attract students
our scholarships are generous but
they're not that generous so it makes a
slight difference but moistu ins come to
university on the basis of the subject
they're interested and the reputation of
the institution there are concerns about
the quality of some rapidly expanding
courses we think it's really important
that universities across the board take
the opportunity to expand so that there
are places for people from across
society at those most selective
institutions as well as the many other
institutions that have great outcomes
for young people and I think the risk
there is that we don't create a two-tier
system
universities are already competing
fiercely to attract students for those
getting their results today there will
be more choice than ever but will those
choices really brighten their future
effleurage Sky News